[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission vous
conseille des livres à lire par exemple
cet été et je vous conseille de le livre
Lefranc le lac au miroir qui parait chez
Viviani bonjour bonjour Patrice Carmouze
alors c'est votre premier on peut parler
de roman même s'il y a un personnage on
va avoir qui est un personnage qui a
vraiment existé qui s'appelle Walter
space qui était un peintre un musicien
aussi mais surtout un peintre qui a vécu
notamment à Bali exactement oui c'est un
roman c'est une fiction c'est une
fiction
alors on va on va évidemment en parler
le lac au miroir c'est d'ailleurs le
titre d'un des tableaux de Walter space
que l'héroïne avait dans sa chambre
quand elle était et enfin on va y
revenir mais avant de porter le roman on
va parler un tout petit peu de votre
parcours vous avez commencé plutôt par
le théâtre oui oui j'ai commencé par
écrire pour le théâtre et aussi pour la
poésie voilà et en fait ce qui
m'intéressait c'était à la dimension
orale c'était de porter des textes sur
scène de crier sa voix de de se faire
entendre peut-être et puis petit à petit
je me suis tournée vers l'écriture aux
manesque c'est quand même la forme
littéraire reine encore dans la
littérature en France donc pour franchir
une maison d'édition les portes d'une
maison d'édition c'est important d'avoir
une formidable maison d'édition
je suis très fière je pense que vous
pouvez être fier oui vous disiez une
tradition orale qu'est-ce qui c'est très
différent d'écrire pour le théâtre ou
d'écrire un roman oui je trouve que
c'est différent parce qu'en fait en fait
moi j'étais fascinée par l'unité de lieu
de d'action du théâtre la parole comme
action dramatique et puis la poésie
c'est aussi un élixir du présent et
passer à la forme romanes que ça demande
un peu de temps puisque ce sont pas les
mêmes c'est pas le même la même forme ce
n'est pas la même structure et donc j'ai
mis du temps pour pour y arriver
sur ce livre mais non je dis ça parce
qu'il y avait
cette anecdote ou cette histoire que
tout le monde connaît c'est Flaubert le
Gaulois
il hurlait des phrases qui mettaient
après dans ces romans parce qu'il y a
aussi une musique dans la dans la phrase
et une musique parfois qu'on entend
mieux à l'oral qu'on ne la voit à
l'écrit exactement la musique alité
d'un texte quand on le crie à l'oral
enfin quand on le crie on fait d'abord
entendre aussi le jeu narratif de
l'écrivain la voix de l'écrivain et ça
permet aussi de d'entendre si elle est
juste
et puis il est et puis il y a beaucoup
de personnages on va en parler chaque
personnage à sa propre voix aussi sa
propre son propre rythme sa propre
musique alors c'est vrai que j'ai pas
crié tout mon roman
mais certains passages effectivement
le style est quelque chose de
d'important très important et c'est vrai
que ce roman est peut-être une synthèse
j'allais dire de mes savoir-faire j'ai
voulu montrer que dans ce livre
peut-être j'ai voulu rassembler tout ce
que j'avais travaillé ces dernières
années la recherche documentaire
justement parce qu'il y a une recherche
documentaire aussi on va en parler
justement sur Walter space
et puis oui donc et le style parce que
le style était évidemment le livre c'est
aussi le style quoi
je te remercie est-ce qu'il vous a
poussé convaincu finalement de de sauter
le pas et d'aller vers le vers le roman
ça fait longtemps que je travaillais en
parallèle en tout cas ce roman ce qui
m'a convaincu de le faire c'est qu'à
force de travailler la structure
narrative j'étais un peu asséchée et
j'avais besoin de me laisser
complètement aller dans l'écriture et ce
roman il est il est né comme ça aussi
un plaisir d'exotisme de voyage de
voyager par l'écriture et donc comme
j'étais allée à Bali bah je forcément
des premiers mots
dès le début c'est pas dit qu'il s'est
invité dans ce monde voilà imposé ouais
un mot aussi sur parce qu'on parle de
théâtre de poésie et il y a la peinture
évidemment avec ce fils c'est vous êtes
aussi fasciné par la peinture
de la peinture avec son évolution la
représentation du monde et puis son
démantèlement petit à petit on voit dans
le 20e siècle et c'est vrai que Walter
spi ça arrive à ce moment d'une très
grande avant garde européenne au début
du 20e siècle et il va se passer par
toutes ces questionnements puisqu'on
voit qu'il a un héritier
d'expressionnisme allemand et puis il a
un
héritier aussi du Douanier Rousseau il
s'inscrit dans cette influence là et
dans ces tableaux il va essayer de faire
de faire une synthèse aussi de tous ces
savoir-faire de musicalité de lumière
mais aussi de son amour pour Bali il va
essayer de le retranscrire dans ses
tableaux
pour donner alors quelques références
biographies je crois qu'il est né à la
fin du 19e siècle 1895 il est mort en 42
je crois
et et donc on voit bien la période
fondamental pour la peinture entre entre
ces deux dates
il sait il s'est réfugié si je peux dire
baby disons qu'il a cherché un lieu où
il pouvait être lui-même voilà parce
qu'il faut
mais c'est un personnage intéressant et
puis à la rigueur très contemporains
aujourd'hui parce que Valter space il
est né dans la Russie impériale
14 prisonnier effet prisonnier donc il a
été exilé dans l'est de l'Oural et
ensuite il s'est évadé et il est revenu
en Allemagne là il a été l'amant de
murnaud
homosexuel un monde murnaud il a
travaillé sur Nosferatu donc on sent
aussi son héritage de de ce cinéma très
dans les obscurités sont très prononcées
et puis il a voulu chercher un peu sa
propre voix et il est parti sur un
bateau il a pris la nationalité russe et
sur un bateau néerlandais il s'est fait
passer pour un russe pendant
traverser et il est arrivé aux Indes
néerlandaise à l'époque et l'ancien
Indonésie et là-bas il a été pianiste
dans un cinéma China chinois exactement
très bon musicien il a été l'élève de
Scream et là-bas ça a été le premier
Européen à travailler pour le sultan
yoga carta donc c'est quelqu'un qui
franchissait aussi un peu tous les
tabous c'est à dire que jamais un colon
aurait été employé par par un autochtone
et lui en fait il osait tout il
osait tout il aimait Bali il aimait la
musique donc il a beaucoup retranscrit
les peintures les musiques de gamelan la
danse aussi et ça a été un peu un
passeur de la culture baselineuse vers
l'Occident puisque il était ami de
Chaplin Artaud a découvert une danse
d'exorciste parce qu'il avait remis
en chorégraphie dans une exposition
coloniale à Paris voilà en fait ça a été
un
vous l'avez découvert comment en allant
à Bali
parce que il a exposé il y a quelques
toiles d'exposés à Ubud où il a beaucoup
vécu et puis après dans mes recherches
puisque j'avais cette histoire de cette
mère de mon héroïne qui est née à
adresse dit je me disais ce serait bien
qu'il y a un peintre qui soit passé par
Bali et qui soit passe par dresser et il
s'avère que pasteur spi c'est passé par
donc j'avais un peu aussi
ce personnage vous a évidemment inspiré
et puis c'est bien parce que honnêtement
je ne le connaissais pas vous faites
vous faites découvrir un personnage
absolument formidable alors on va le
début du livre ça se passait les ruines
s'appelle Ana Springer alors une
quarantaine d'années
elle vit en Australie là elle se trouve
il se trouve que elle est à Bali et là
elle apprend la mort de sa mère
et sa mère l'a pas vu depuis 20 ans
voilà pourquoi bah parce qu'elle avait
décidé de rompre avec sa mère puisque sa
mère ne lui refusait divulguer certains
secrets que je ne dirai pas et du coup
c'est
pas voilà et donc en fait
voilà et donc elle a décidé puisque
c'est ça de couper les ponts et essayer
de commencer une nouvelle vie mais bien
souvent on pense qu'on repond tout en
partant loin on pourra commencer une
nouvelle page blanche et ce n'est pas le
cas elle est rattrapée par elle est
rattrapée et au fond la mort de de sa
mère prend la mort de sa mère ça va la
conduire à aller reprendre ses
recherches sur ses origines sur ses
origines sur les secrets sur les secrets
et ça va la conduire à marcher sur les
traces de Valter spi c'est finalement
dans la chambre de Anna notamment le
tableau qui s'appelait le lac au miroir
et qui ont disparu voilà qui ont disparu
et
oui
il y a une phrase comme ça qui m'a
frappé parce que c'est justement
très très significatif sur ce rapport à
la mère elle dit un mot tu sais que
maman est un mot que j'avais barré dans
le dictionnaire
[Musique]
et
au téléphone ça met et alors et alors
c'est une réaction plus riche de ma part
c'était l'inverse que j'espérais écrire
maman en majuscule en fait c'est ça il
veut cette rupture c'était c'était une
rupture par la force des choses mais au
fond la quête de l'identité la quête de
qui était vraiment cette merde qui était
son père ainsi ça n'a jamais quitté non
ça ne l'a jamais quitté et puis en fait
on est parfois animés de comme je dis
des fois la haine est un excès d'amour
voilà avec cette mère elle avait à la
fois un amour fou et en même temps un
sentiment de de elle lui en voulait une
rancoeur et
finalement elle se rend compte que sa
quête la mienne aussi à vouloir se
réconcilier avec sa mère en tout cas à
la comprendre
vous dites aussi en parlant de la mer
elle avait brûlé sa vie comme si elle
était donc proie aux perpétuel dilemme
de rester ou de fuir
un peu du mal à connaître et à
comprendre
quelqu'un qui ne se laisse pas qui est
énigmatique qu'une seule laisse pas
attraper ou connaître complètement qui a
toujours besoin d'avoir une sortie de
secours pour pouvoir
aussi une sorte pour le lecteur une
sorte d'enquête policière
alors on va pas dire jusque où ça va
mener parce que enfin
je sais pas s'il faut dire ou pas dans
peut-être pas des tableaux pourquoi ils
ont disparu oui peut-être qu'on va pas
le dire
parce que
comment divulgâché
alors le le roman nous fait évidemment
vous voyez parce que Baldi qui est très
important
d'où vient alors cet amour pour Bali et
je pense que Bali quand on y va on sait
que c'est une
île qui vous transforme de toute façon
c'est il se passe quelque chose là-bas
tellement il y a une présence d'un monde
invisible je dirais c'est une ville
c'est pas juste de vacances quoi il
y a plus de 10000 temples des
tout-petits des grands il y avait
vraiment un lien avec l'invisible c'est
à dire que
on a l'impression que c'est c'est une
île bonne idée Dieu quand même il y a
quelque chose d'un paradis alors bien
sûr maintenant il y a du tourisme de
masse mais
il y a autre chose
je pense qu'on part à Bali parce qu'on a
une recherche un peu de de d'exotisme
c'est une île très douce aussi
le climat est vraiment agréable les
Balinais sont absolument accueillants et
puis voilà vous avez tout là-bas vous
allez la montagne si on y va pour le
tourisme vous avez la montagne vous avez
pu faire du surf de la plongée
il y a des volcans il y a des paysages
incroyables
et il y a les tableaux de Walters
balinaise c'est quand ils ont un art de
la marionnette impressionnant et puis
les danses balinaises aussi sont
elles ont inspiré en tout cas toute une
tradition théâtrale en France et
la question des des origines elle était
essentielle pour vous
je pense qu'elle est essentielle en tout
cas ce qui est important c'est la
question des origines elle pose la
question de bien sûr de savoir d'où l'on
vient du chez nous manquant là c'est par
exemple la notion de paternité mais
c'est peut-être aussi de peut-être mieux
la question des origines pour moi elle
vient interroger aussi la question de
l'héritage que l'on reçoit dans son
éducation dans la compréhension aussi de
sa généalogie je pense que c'est une
question aussi très contemporaine
aujourd'hui on est dans un dans un dans
une capacité à pouvoir se renseigner sur
d'où l'on vient avec les tests ADN etc
on le voit même avec les enfants qui ont
été adoptés ou qui sont nés même
chose comme ça on va ouvrir justement la
possibilité
ses origines parce que sans doute parce
que c'est essentiel c'est essentiel et
puis en même temps je pense que dans mon
roman en tout cas ce que j'ai voulu
montrer c'est qu'on a quand même
beaucoup de personnages solitaires qui
se cherche une famille et que cette
famille en tout cas il y a un possible
de pouvoir se choisir les siens
indépendamment de réponse qu'on
recherche sur ces origines et c'est ça
aussi que je voulais montrer dans mon
livre oui il faut dire c'est ça il y a
beaucoup de personnes il y a notamment
un personnage que l'héroïne rencontre à
Baldi qui est absolument fabuleux enfin
c'est vrai que voilà il y a pas que il y
a pas que le peintre la mère disparaît
l'héroïne est beaucoup beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de robes qui évidemment dans ce
livre est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a des secrets il y a des
secrets de famille évidemment mais
est-ce qu'il y a des secrets indicible
ce qui est des secrets qu'il faut pas
dire qu'il faut pas découvrir ah ça
c'est une vraie question simplement je
pense qu'il y a des secrets qui se
transmettent
inconsciemment puisque quand on ne veut
pas pas dire quelque chose on a un
comportement ou en tout cas on a une
façon de nier quelque chose qui a existé
et que en tout cas les enfants peuvent
ressentir et à un moment donné il y aura
si c'est pas dans la génération suivante
c'est la génération d'après il y aura le
désir de connaître c'est très important
d'ailleurs dans votre livre c'est plutôt
les générations d'après qui
encore une fois je veux
le gâcher mais c'est important il y a
ceux qui ont fait puis il y a des
enfants et des petits enfants voilà et
peut-être ça te saute une génération
vous pourrez être dit des secrets je
sais pas
parfois ça ça saute une génération
parfois aussi on comprend que il y a un
besoin de retour de retour vers le passé
quand on parle de quête des origines
mais on fait aussi avec notre histoire
aujourd'hui on est dans des questions de
déconstruction de notre de notre
héritage universaliste donc je pense que
ça intéressant aussi de de comprendre
pourquoi on a besoin de déconstruire
pourquoi on a besoin de regarder
autrement la manière dont aujourd'hui on
raconte l'histoire et aussi pourquoi
on on
est-ce que il peut y avoir une
réconciliation aussi avec l'héritage que
l'on a parce qu'on peut pas jeter le Lot
et le bébé l'eau du bain enfin voilà
c'est voilà
disait qu'il y avait beaucoup de
personnages dans dans ce roman souvent
on dit l'auteur c'est le personnage
principal donc ça serait plutôt Anna en
réalité non parce que un auteur il est
dans tous les personnages et est-ce
qu'il y a dans dans les personnages que
vous décrivez ce qu'il y en a un
finalement vous sentez plus proche alors
je me sens proche d'un des personnages
mais je pense que je suis ressemble pas
tellement
mais c'est vrai que je me sens proche de
joty parce qu'en fait je pense que
l'héroïne rencontre à Bali absolument
formidable en fait j'ai inventé des
personnages que j'aurais rêvé de
rencontrer Joey je pense que j'aurais
rêvé de la rencontrer un certain moment
et effectivement après je me sens proche
peut-être de tous les personnages je
peux dire que je j'éprouve là la rancœur
de la ligne je peux la ressentir je peux
ressentir la rancœur Paloma comme je
peux ressentir l'indifférence de
Fabrizio enfin voilà on est on est fait
d'ombre et de lumière et je crois avoir
même si pour reprendre tout le monde
disait Madame Bovary c'est moi mais mais
enfin en auteur est dans tous les
personnages je pense qu'il écrit enfin
il est dans tout mais en fait là c'est
vraiment une fiction et puis c'est vrai
que à travers le personnage d'annaï à ce
questionnement aussi du sujet narratif
et c'est pour ça que je pense que c'est
un travail en tout cas que j'essaye
d'approfondir de cette émergence comme
parler de Roland Barthe du sujet du jeu
et du jeu de l'écrivain et ça je pense
que c'est le Gaulois aide à ça aussi à
faire émerger ce jeu de
l'écrivains
ce qui va créer la vie c'est le désir
vous y croyez ouais j'y crois ouais
ouais j'y crois alors ça c'est une
phrase qu'on m'a dit à Bali alors ça
ouais j'étais dans un
lieu alors là c'était là c'était pas un
vieux monsieur qui m'a dit cette phrase
mais c'était un un bel idée d'ailleurs
et il pleuvait c'était la nuit et c'est
vrai qu'à Bali dès que vous êtes dans un
temple et que la nuit tombe la nuit
tombe le taux dans les tropiques
et bien il y a la jungle il y a la pluie
enfin vous êtes un peu dans une
atmosphère et un peu irréelle quoi et
quand on entend cette phrase au milieu
de la c'est étonnant voilà c'est
étonnant et une autre phrase tout finira
un jour le ciel dans sa perpétuité la
terre dans sa durée mais jamais ne
s'épuisera cette douleur sans fin
je pense qu'il y a des blessures en
guérissables
tout finit la douleur elle reste la
douleur elle reste ouais je pense que il
y a des des blessures d'ailleurs qui
restent un guérissa parce que
elles sont constituantes d'une
personnalité elles sont constituantes
d'une d'un parcours de vie
et il reste
alors
voilà si vous aimez le voyage parce que
vous allez si vous aimez vous allez
découvrir donc peut-être se battre vous
le connaissiez
si vous aimez la peinture si vous aimez
aussi une enquête enfin l'histoire
parce qu'on va on va Drèze aussi on va
en France il y a pas dit évidemment dans
le centre et bien vous lisez l'ACO
miroir dont il Lefranc aux éditions Vivi
Adami merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
merci de m'avoir invité merci et là vous
êtes autre chose j'essaye de travailler
oui sur un sur un roman voilà c'est
facile non c'est pas facile
parce que là vous avez beaucoup comme
vous disiez j'ai mis beaucoup beaucoup
vous allez alors c'est au mois d'octobre
à tout de suite mais c'est très bien de
le dire c'est dans une librairie qui
vient de rouvrir à plaisir qui s'appelle
plaisir de lire c'est la alors il y
avait plus de librairies indépendante à
Plaisir celle-là vient de rouvrir ses
portes il faut donc il faut les
féliciter ils vont le souhaiter donc vie
et leur longue vie passe par votre
visite elle passe par une visite elles
organisent de nombreuses soirées
culturelles à partir d'octobre et moi je
serai à plaisir donc le 19 octobre pour
une rencontre dédicace autour du lac au
miroir
la plaisir de lire à plaisir c'est que
du plaisir
c'était ma première télé donc peut-être
avec le libraire ça serait bien
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]